For the experiments that have been added, the
child in the name of lecture surgeon, son, whatever
new topics have been added which are
not in your NCRT, we are the first one,
we had eliminated all those topics by bringing out a series of seven days.
Be it
Botany, Zoology, Physics, Chemistry,
we have finished the topics of all the four subjects,
you
can already go and watch them in the live class, you will
get all the new topics of all the four subjects on it,
when the NMC circular came, only
then we were there.  Very sure, NT did
not put a seal of confirmation on it, the syllabus which has
been decided by NMC will remain the same syllabus, that we are very
sure, that is why we have
taught all those topics to you children,
we have taught all the new families.
Jaljeera has been added, we have already
taught you Physics, Chemistry everything,
we have taught you everything,
okay